NEW QUESON
ROARRD,
EMBATTLED  SECURIT
TOGED  M
2021, YEHE THE
CAPITOL RIOT MAY HAVE
6tPONT THE SECRET WAS WITH TRUA
AND THE FORMER PNT FOUGHTHGEY R
TESTIFNGERNIT JUST THE ERVICE T
CNN AL LS FROM OMHIEF,
CH HIS TOP DEPUTY, N E AL
CUCCINELLI IS KE HAD
BEY TRUMP TOEI
DEUE G MACHINE O FORMER ACTING
WHO ALSO TESTIFIED UNDER OATH.
PHONE,WAS NUMBER TWOS
AT THE TIME.
I S ON SPEAKAND HE SAID, KEN, IG
GENERAL.LD MS YOUR JOB  YOU'R
J WHITND "OutFront" LIVIN WASHT
OME MEHE ARE YEAG AB HAPPENED AU
T THESE OVERT UCA
OF THE MNGTOR GENERAL WAID PRIO
OF DECEMBER 2021AS THE
THE INSPECTOR S AL. M ERASED INM
SEVEN MONTHS EARLIER T
PREVIOUSLY KNOTHE SECRETERVI H D
T MESSAGES WERE LOSTIOUSLY, IN
DATI OF
EN PHONES. INTERESTED BEE, AS
INHE PEOPLE
T DAY AN THE CENTER OF JANUARY H
ONE OF THE KEY PROBLEMS
THAT KEY PERSONNEL INSID
SECRET SERVICERETH
ACDISAPPR WHENTH DTION.
E BACK SOMEWHERENDT E
THIS WASLY ABSOLUTELY THATEY.Y E
PHONE PROVIDE TORE TM UT
THE OTHER THIN
ABOUT - ERE NOTIFIED IN MA
THEY WERE ER. TDEPARTMENT OMEUR
T
THAT WAS JULY , MOREEFORSPECTOLS
ALSO AN AGENCY IN CHARGE OF
POLICINGRI
OVERSI
WHITNEY WILDT REPORTING.
REOEHOMELA
TO VICE PRIDNC SHI
EISEN SERVED
DEMOCRATS  T'S FIRST
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL AN AITE ETHICS
YOU WORKED AT
ONE,OW
W ONNOTEPS
TO BUTO WAITO REPORT
CO>> YEAH.
IT'S A LSURPRISING, LOOK, I HAVW
TECHNICAL MIGRATIONS
AND  ITHAT PEOPLE
AWARE THESE MESSAGINALLY W
F PLANNING TCAD .
BUT ALSO, LOOK,  FROEN YOU WORA
KIND PEOPLE' ADMINISYO
LIE.N THAT I
ABOUUMP AD
RATHER TN GOG
AND I'LL JUST SAY THAT.
RE
THAT YOUNDE S I' TELL YOU, BEINN
MINISTRATION COMMUTECRYPTED SIG.
HEEAT
IT A
YOU CAN EITHERURN INGOS THER ENR
>>YO IPOSIT,, I.
THESE ESRG
RISO FORRET HE ML ICE THE REAGAN
THWAE THREAT TO E CAPITOL.
IS THICE THAT YO
SEE HEREIN
>> JIM, USUYOARTEHATHAT'S WHY D
I HAVE MINE. IS BEYOND INCOMPET.
ANY INSPECTOR NERAL, W
SECURITY, DOESN'T WOSAY,HEAD OF
CONGRESS. C
AND SAY YOU CAT T ONGOINHERE ARF
REPOG THINK THRAHAS
TH SAYAN
BE, WHAT THE THEHIEF INFTI
IF YOU'RE MIGRFOR
UP WITH A
MANUAL TYPEWRITER ,
NOT ONLY BECAU YOUPPOSED
O THAT BUT THE LAW SAYS YOU
SPECTOR GENERAION OFFICER AT DHS
UST EANS THEIR CAREERSTO
ENGANIZATI.THERE'S NOTION ICAN
IT WAS PART OF YOUR JO
THA ADMINISTRATION.
BEYOND LG RE
LEGALISM INDICNSARE. LEVEL OF
AND TO PY
CONVINCES ARE WE TO HAVELVING S
R
HAS CONFRONTED I J.
TOKING A
HARD WGE.
IT WAS NOT NEGLIGENCE, THAT IT
OLIVIA, THIS ASALSO LEARNING MR
TRUMP'
THIS PATTERN WE'RE DISCUSSING.NN
SPEAKSUNICATIONSWOULD BE OF IMP
ITN.Y LL
IT W
AND UT A
TSN GEAT
C OF .C.EWHOSE NAME HE HAD..E.
PAMELANDAS REAO  MAK
AND HE SAID FINE.
IVE UNDERSTACAN YOU HAVEUSAT
KEN, MI,
KNOWS ABTHSAID FINE.
I WOULD PASS THAT ALONG TO HIM
HOCCINELO TRUMP'S
EFFORTS, HIS ATTEMPTEDURN THE EA
E  T CAMELE
I SAW HIM IN THET
D HESEOROFT THAT HE ATIOE EXTENS
AND I'LL SAY THIS, I HOPE
TH SEE MEUNICATIONS AAL F WENON.
TO POINTSPE
IMPORTANCE OF THE JAARh OMK INI.
BEE OF THIBOR REALIZTHF THIS E